you know he's considering should he put
his bishop in the middle of the board
should he try to go for something else
and so he's gone for the king
move okay
wow okay so white might continue with
the plan but white tonight also has the
opportunity at some point now to try and
jump out of its cage from uh on the edge
of the board
it can jump forward i don't think that
really helps at the moment
uh that's the first move i would
calculate actually you know because it's
a consequence of black's last move okay
he does it jump in with the knight and
if that knight starts
attacking some pawns on the right
they're gonna fall actually maybe magnus
has a route to try and win a black
central pawn i was worried here about
black's king stepping forward in front
of white's extra pawn oh there we go and
now white knight can actually give a
check
uh i don't think you want to go to any
other square you might get trapped or it
can step back actually wait it's
stepping towards the black horn maybe
magnus is winning suddenly yeah
wow we've seen a turnaround wow eric has
just let the white knight back into the
game
i played that move with less than one
second left
and he's losing his pawns those pawns
now the g black g6 pawn it's fallen yeah
and those pawns are way more important
than pawns on the other side of the
board black's kings and just not
participating now it's in no man's land
and uh now he's got the best type of
pawn it's a protect it's a pass pawn and
the bishop he will win the bishop wow we
talked about squeezing water out of the
stone that has happened in this game it
was just a dead draw eric had it almost
within its uh within his grasp
and here we go black bishop has to stop
the white pawn but after this capture
that white pawn is going to cost black
his bishop and eric resigns magnus
squeezed out the win oh wow both players
shaking their heads